all right Pilots bring it in I've
retired from the MVP race of my own
accord oh okay so you were clearly
voiced out anyway I'll be your eye in
the sky and this is your flight path do
you understand looks alright to me or
should I say all left
my mommy hurts who's the only undefeated
pilot left
I was ordered to stand down by my
Superior commanders and I actually
follow a protocol
this year it's an airplane race there
for takeoff is three two one
let's put a little more air under it I'm
not sure we can keep this up why does
everyone keep saying that to me you know
G plain for me the Original Gangster
Kirk cousin this is so easy
oh no it's the jet
streams Gino is that a glider yes indeed
you know it can only go so far right I
know coach we're almost out of field
does does anyone receive me where did
that come from but it's not Blitz
goodbye frog man don't worry folks we
have taken out the defender
Yo cool here who's the visibility need a
read here one shotgun
there's a mountain
Eagles Fly
don't make any stupid mistakes Josh no
come on do something Reckless that
sounds fun fairly days
[Applause]
[Music]
how is this guy still flying under the
radar they're approaching the final
turn-along press row and two are
surprises hurt just like at the Academy
Sports not again
that speed they'll never be able to
survive the pressure J force is too much
I still don't think two is that good I
can win MVP I have one I can win MVP
look how we're gonna go
let's just avoid any unforced errors
it's like we always say you can't make
an omelet without breaking a few tables
uh oh snow better move to Detroit for a
week Jakes
foreign